good morning John sometimes I feel like
those three words
good morning John are the most important
words that we say in these videos not
only does it help to remind me that you
John Green are the most important member
of the audience that I am speaking to
right now it also puts every single
vlogbrothers video into the context of
every other vlogbrothers video whether
we're talking about anglerfish or the
French Revolution when the over
intellectualization of a three word
sentence that begins our vidiq this
isn't what I wanted this is boring this
is boring boring boring to talk about
the fair
I love the fair it is ridiculous let's
be honest I mostly go for the food I
only get one opportunity a year to have
a hand dipped corndog and I am NOT gonna
miss that sometimes I think that maybe I
invented my obsession with corndogs
because it's funny because the word
corndog is funny but look at my face
right there that's when I'm just like so
overwhelmed with melty crunchy batter in
that sweet juicy meat in an unrelated
story I was filming this big sheep
because I was like that's a really big
sheep and then something came from
behind it and scared it and I was like
but fair as far as I'm concerned has
everything a man could want it's got
deep-fried meatballs and deep-fried
cheese curds
deep-fried vikings and deep-fried corn
dogs and llamas and chickens and geese
and ducks and bunnies and eerily violent
lego themed star wars sets that's weird
so in other news i've been suffering
from severe brain crack lately two huge
projects that are just like and then
last night I was tweeting that I think I
may stop all going to see movies if I
haven't read the book first I feel like
it ruins it and then I got a lot of
people who were agreeing with me on that
and then I made up a logo for a website
called read it first and then I put that
logo on my tumblr and then people
commented on it and then we did like a
back and forth and we had a really great
design critique session and it was super
fun and so now I've got that brain crack
too so I have to start work I bought the
domain name so I'm already ten dollars
in and honestly this isn't the kind of
idea that would even be possible without
nerdfighteria so thanks so much to
nerdfighteria for supporting this and
also for being a source of tremendous
inspiration for me speaking of which
john green's stop watching the video
right now so yeah august 24th is one of
the 365 days in the year is it important
for some reason if you're curious about
that go to nerdfighters comm and sign up
for the little sign up thing on the left
hand side right left I don't know you
need to sign over the next two days and
if you do that you can find out how
participate in some August 24th
celebrity oceans celebratory
you're not watching anymore but
nonetheless I'll see you on Monday